the Carolina Panthers tight end Pro
Bolton and entering his 11th year in the
National Football League out of the you
Greg Olson how are you Greg I'm doing
great doing great rich good to be on as
always know I love having you on 11th so
this is your 11th training camp I mean
when you say that it sounds it's hard to
believe you believe how is the 11th
training camp different from your first
you know I don't think there's that you
know there's not that rookie anxiety
that unknown you know kind of getting
your feet under you a little bit you
know the harder part now is your
warm-ups are a little bit longer you're
you don't recover quite as fast as you
used to I remember those rookie days you
didn't know it you didn't know anything
but the only thing you could do is you
could run around for days on end now
it's like the complete opposite you know
everything you know where to go you know
the plays but you don't quite have the
same juice that you used to so a lovely
was the coach there right when you first
got there yeah 2007 and and Urlacher
well how do Urlacher treat you when you
walked in there Greg he was awesome he
I've said it every time I get a chance
you know the way he kind of wrapped his
arms around me and kind of showed me
what it was like to be a pro from from
day one I'll never forget one day I was
in the weight room and you know whatever
the exercise was bench or whatever was
we're lifting as a team and you know I'm
down and I look up and there's a guy
standing behind me yeah you mind if I
work if I work in and I kind of look
back and you know there you know there's
Brian Urlacher asking a rookie if he can
just work in as opposed to just take in
my benching you know from there we
really you know developed a good
relationship a good friendship and you
know he's a guy that you know I owe a
lot to just kind of show me what it what
it means to be a pro and how to treat
people and you know he was as good as it
gets
what do you think of Cutler coming back
and going to Miami Greg I think he's
going to do great I called it from the
day the report came out on Tanner I said
I said everybody at camp we were sitting
in the cafeteria you watch he's going to
come back out he's gonna hook back up
with gates you're gonna get is gonna get
reorganized healthy all that and he's
going to have a good year I mean they
got a lot of good offensive players down
there good running game you know there's
I think I think he's got a chance down
there too I think he's got to do really
well I know again you're you're you're
from afar and this is not your situation
and I am going to get to your current
situation in a second
what what is it about gays did you think
that that gets to Cutler in a way that
other other coaches or even other
teammates have not been able to correct
it's a good question I obviously spend
time with Jay I have never you know been
around or I don't really know much about
about gays but you know just knowing Jay
obviously he has a lot of comfort he has
a lot of trust and with Jay I think
that's really big guys that he really
believes in guys that he really trusts
and feels comfortable with he excels at
and you know he excels with those guys
so you know it's pretty clear from from
their history and track record that that
you know you don't just come out of
retirement for anybody so I think that
was a very unique situation and just
kind of placed to that level of trust
that he has with gates down there to you
know kind of come off the couch so to
speak and kind of hit the ground running
as the day 1 starter of camp so I think
that says a lot
obviously Jays script you know has a ton
of talent he's played at a high level
and I think with some guys around him
and it caught in a system that he knows
and likes I think he should do well is
there is there a coach like that for you
and your career Greg Olson but you have
that connection with you know you know
I've been lucky I've you know I haven't
had it I've had two head coaches my
whole career I've had a couple offensive
coordinators it's kind of funny now on
this staff you know obviously we have
Mike Shula now and then as an offensive
consultant we just hired Ron Turner who
was who was my offensive coordinator
when I got drafted in Chicago so you
know pretty much the only two offensive
coordinators that I know and we had chud
for a short while here before he took
the Cleveland job and then obviously I
had the one-year with marks but you know
the to the 200 seeds that I've worked
the most which now are both on our staff
so it's kind of funny full circle how
that kind of works from that one year
was March is why you're calling me from
Carolina right now yeah exactly that one
year from Marcus but uh I kind of said
all these events into acting it was all
where it was all meant to be that's one
way to put it the dominoes started
tumbling Greg Olson joining that was the
first domino yes sir so what's going on
with cam tell me about his shoulder here
best you can
Greg you know he started off camp you
know doing well you really look like you
use really throwing the ball well first
four or five days
you know then I think you know all part
of the plan all along was we knew there
was going to be some ups and downs you
know obviously was a it was a
significant shoulder injury for a you
know throwing you know quarterback
throwing you know athlete is always
tough and you know I think all along the
doctors and everyone anticipated that
there'd be some ups and downs but you
know just seeing them out there and
practice running around still heavily
involved throws on the side so I think
they have a a pretty smart plan in place
a pitch count so to speak and they'll
just start slowly easing them back in
here now and try to keep that thing
under control so I think you know I
think we got four weeks still or so 28
29 days or whatever it is till opening
day so I think I I think everyone's
optimistic that it will work out okay
and last we spoke
Christian McCaffrey was still not able
to join your team essentially because of
the rule that you have to graduate or
your school has to have had its
graduation before the kid can join the
team Stanford's graduated now McCaffrey
has been around now that you've been
able to highball him tell me what you
think of him he's impressive I think you
know I think from afar we all knew the
the talent that he was going to bring
you know we all saw his you know we all
saw what he did in college running the
ball you know inside you know out space
with the ball and return game you know I
think the physical stuff we all do I
think you know coming in and and I think
the most impressive thing with him has
been you know he kind of has the
demeanor and kind of the attitude of a
veteran you can tell he's been around an
NFL locker he knows how to take care of
his body he knows how to conduct himself
he just has a different a different look
on his face and a different look in his
eye than a traditional rookie who's you
know real wide-eyed and kind of taking
everything you know flying at them he
kind of has a more sense of calm and
more sense of alright I got this you
know I know what I'm doing here so you
know he's an impressive young kid he's
only 21 years old but maybe has a
maturity level you know significantly
higher than that so what what are the
goals here Greg you guys talking Super
Bowl openly getting back there I mean
it's just only been two years not even
since you were there
what what are you talking about yeah you
know I think I think obviously that is
the ultimate goal for everybody
if you ask they're all 32 teams that's
the ultimate goal but I think the
biggest thing we talk about the kind of
got away from us a little last year is
you know let's just let's let's have the
best training camp we can let's you know
let's put together the best group of
guys that when we go into week one we're
ready to roll and then when it becomes
week one let's start winning games one
week at a time and start putting
together a little bit of a run I think
that's really what we did the Super Bowl
year and I don't think we all started
that year saying oh we're going to win
17 games I think we want one game and
next thing you know it turned five turn
to ten and you know you start putting
them together and you start building
confidence and momentum you know we got
to get back to this year so we got to
win one you know and then you talked
about winning the division and then the
kind of season that just kind of plays
itself out so our expectations are high
I think are in our potential is high but
you know in this league you know I think
that's pretty much the case can be made
for everybody a couple more minutes left
with Greg Olson here on the Rich Eisen
show and anybody who knows you and your
story with your wife and your family you
know that that life is fragile I'm
wondering after the report that came out
on regards to CTE being found in a
hundred and ten out of a hundred and
eleven brains of players that played
football what the conversation was like
with you if you wouldn't mind sharing
with your family and after you you heard
this Greg yeah I think hey I think for
all of us especially that have played
this game for a long time you know we
played this game you know six years old
and you know now playing in the NFL for
11 years you know this has been a game
that obviously has been very good to me
in a game that you know it's really all
I've known almost my entire life it's
been a game that's been you know a big
part of it but you know those statistics
are of course startling and they are and
they of course get your attention and
you know I just don't think you could be
you know naive about it and totally
dismiss it but I also think there's a
part where I think there's a lot of
information left to be had and I think
the when you read the reports as a lot
of us have you know even the doctors
that are conducting these studies are
the first to say you know you know it's
conducting Studies on you know non
football players and get a little bit
more of a control group and and really
start diving into what these numbers
mean so you know of course we never want
to see anybody football player or not
you know have struggles later in life
and if there's ways you know at this
point during their career
here immediately after that we can curb
some of these results I think we'd all
be the first to sign up for that but you
know to say that I'm going to
second-guess playing football or
anything like that you know I'm not it
football is a game that you know like I
said has been a big part of my life my
whole you know since I can remember it's
obviously been very good to me it's
something that I still this long really
still enjoy doing so I'm not going to
you know I'm not going to second-guess
that we all know what we signed up for
you know there's there's no one forcing
us to do this and this is something
we've all chosen to do and I think the
safe route you know we can make it as
safe as we can of course and some of the
other risks I think just kind of come
with the territory and you're living
your life and so while you are playing
with courtyard you're hooking up with
the comedian Ben Schwartz and you also
tried your hand at acting this offseason
at The Upright Citizens Brigade and we
also saw your cameo and Khalil's mock
you of mockumentary if you will of Cam
Newton's video it seems like you're
having fun with that correct your
comedian now it was not far from the
commitment and was the comedian that for
anybody who's seen Ben Schwartz he's
he's brilliant he's so he's hilarious
he's smart we had an absolute blast
filming that and you know he kind of
carried me along and made me feel
comfortable we had a really good time
with it it was fun working working with
him for courtyard and and and being a
part of that so people can go check it
out a courtyard YouTube page I hope they
get as big a kick out of it as we as we
had making it and all always we had a
really good time yeah because they're
trying to turn you from a Hollywood
newbie into a red carpet superstar all
you got to do is ask Khalil how that
happens right
no one's more Hollywood than Kalia I
remind him all the time that guys got
that guy just in the him playing centers
like the third best thing that he does
he's an all-pro center it's like it fits
best talent I feel like I said just you
got like bigger thing he's the only guy
that's going to retire and actually move
up in the world
Greg love chat with you always probably
we don't talk before the beginning of
the season when you open up at San
Francisco good luck and then we'll chat
with you during the season
I thank so much rich always a pleasure
likewise that's Greg Olson dad Greg
Olsen 88 on Twitter the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
isn't it amazing you can download an app
with your thumbprint you should download
our app with your thumbprint